Just wanna give you a little weekend recap here at the farm.
So we headed to town and watch the boys play their games.
We hit our neighbor's cattle drive on the way there
and on the way back, so it made us late coming and going.
We are enjoying the most beautiful fall here on the farm.
We got our new ball and calves.
These guys are going into our beef program.
They were just weaned from their mamas and looking so good.
Aubrey came up
and we did a protein powder photo shoot with the animals.
And we also did some stuff in the kitchen with the kids.
Little hands. It's ready to go next week,
which is very exciting. This video made me laugh.
Of the traffic that we had on our driveway as we were leaving.
Then that night,
we had some friends over for the first dinner in a pumpkin of the year.
Then we headed over to the dairy and did our nightly calf eating.